the former president of planned
parenthood so a
former top abortionist in the country
her
job her career was spent
literally killing babies
at to the tune of hundreds of thousands
a year just by planned parenthood alone
she is now on cnn and
she is describing how they are going to
get how the ruling
elite is going to get all you deplorable
irredeemable bitter clinging bible
thumping americans
to take the experimental drug for the
virus that is
so dangerous so terrible that it's got
actually a very very low death rate
and it's so awful and terrible that no
one wants to get the vaccine which is so
wonderful and great
that they're going to make life very
very hard for you
now we have this delta variant that is
much more contagious
because it's more contagious it's going
to be even harder for us to reach herd
immunity we're going to have to
vaccinate
an even higher proportion of people to
get there what happens then
if we end up having another variant
developing that's even more contagious
that could cause more disease that could
evade the protection of our immune
system
and so how quickly we get this under
control and which way we go
depends on what we do now when it comes
to vaccination
to overcoming disinformation and what we
really need to do at this point is to
make vaccination
the easy choice it needs to be hard for
people to remain
unvaccinated right now it's kind of the
opposite it's fine i mean it's easy if
you're unvaccinated you can do
everything you want to do anyway
but at some point these mandates by
workplaces fight schools
i think it will be important to say hey
you can opt out but if you want to opt
out
you have to sign these forms you have to
get twice weekly testing
basically we need to make getting
vaccinated the easy choice that is what
it's going to take for us to actually
end the pandemic
do you see how she gives away the game
here
if the vaccine were so great
well let's back up if the
virus were really so bad if it were
really so dangerous to so many people
it wouldn't matter how experimental or
untested the vaccine where people would
be clamoring to get it if this were the
bubonic plague in medieval europe
people would be clamoring to get any
kind of vaccine they could get
but they're not doing that because
they're not at great risk
then you have to take the question of
the va if the vaccine were so great if
it were so totally 100
safe one you wouldn't be hearing
reports from the cdc by the way i'm not
this is not like from some far off
corner of the internet this is
the cdc in the fda acknowledging that
there are reports of myocarditis and
young young people who are not at
particularly high statistical risk from
covid they're having
issues of heart inflammation heart
hospitalization in some cases death
you wouldn't be hearing reports of the
cova vaccine or the johnson johnson
vaccine which actually had to be paused
because women were getting blood clots
and in some cases dying from the
vaccine you wouldn't be hearing reports
that just came out yesterday reported in
even the new york times for goodness
sakes
of the johnson johnson vaccine causing a
nervous system a nerve issue you
wouldn't be hearing any of those things
which has actually presented itself in
other vaccines even though no one's
allowed to talk about that
you you wouldn't you wouldn't be hearing
about that sort of thing and if the
vaccine
were really so great for the virus
that's really so terrible and deadly and
scary
you wouldn't need to make life hard for
everybody because life would already be
hard for people
because the vaccine would already be the
easy choice but because none of that is
true
they have to contrive it they have to
make pretend
this is something you see
in you see greater
authoritarianism you see greater
repression in regimes that are really
unstable and there is no way i think
right now to look at the
nature of our politics and say that
things are stable nothing is stable
nothing is settled the the radicals the
revolutionaries
in the in the middle of the 20th century
unsettled everything
we can't even say what the difference is
between men and women anymore
not even the conservatives can say what
the difference between men and women is
anymore forget about the radical left
even people who are the right wing
people on the right wing networks even
they
are defending this sort of thing so of
course as things are going to be
unsettled
you're going to see greater oppression
greater repression
are ruling elites intentionally making
life hard for people
to get them to succumb to their will
that sort of thing is not happening just
90 miles off the coast of florida
that sort of thing is happening right in
our own back
yard hold up i'm glad you liked that
clip
go check out the full episode it's
called the perpetual revolution you can
get it here on youtube you ring that
bell you subscribe you get the
notifications you can get it on apple
podcast spotify google play stitch or
myspace saying a live journal wherever
wherever you get your podcasts
we have got a revolution going on here
folks we are going to upend
the ruling dominant desiccated corrupt
liberal regime
but we need your help to do it go check
out all that stuff and viva
siempre la revolucion
[Music]